la vie sera t-elle encore possible
demain sur terre rien n'est moins sûr le
rythme auquel les sociétés produisent et
libère de nouveaux produits chimiques et
d'autres entités nouvelle dans
l'environnement ne permet pas de rester
dans un espace de fonctionnement sûr
pour l'humanité c'est le constat d'une
étude majeure parue dans la revue
environmental science and technology co
réalisée par une équipe de scientifiques
internationaux
il y affirme que sur les neuf limites
planétaires celle des polluants
environnementaux vient d'être franchie
la production de produits chimiques a
été multiplié par 50 depuis 1950 elle
devrait tripler d'ici 2050 dans un
concept popularisé en 2009 ces
scientifiques ont défini neuf variable à
ne pas franchir pour que l'humanité
n'assiste à un changement d'état
irréversible de l'écosystème
parmi eux figurent le changement
climatique les perte de la biodiversité
l'acidification des océans l'usagé des
sols ou encore l'utilisation mondiale de
l'eau la pollution chimique et la
cinquième limite donc que le monde a
franchi au total lé chercheur estime
qu'il n'y a plus de 350000 type de
différents produits chimiques
manufacturés sur le marché mondial on
compte les plastiques bien sûr les
pesticides les produits chimiques
industriels les produits pharmaceutiques
ou encore les produits chimiques
présents dans les produits de
consommation
la vitesse à laquelle ces polluants
apparaissent dans l'environnement
dépasse de loin la capacité des
gouvernements à évaluer les risques
mondiaux et régionaux sans parler de
contrôler les problèmes potentiels
certains de ces polluants peuvent être
trouvées dans le monde entier de
l'arctique à l'antarctique et peuvent
être extrêmement persistant nous avons
des preuves accablantes d'impact négatif
sur les systèmes terrestres y compris la
biodiversité et les cycles
biogéochimiques de graves conséquences
donc pour l'homme et la biodiversité
et pourtant cette annonce est tombée
dans une indifférence quasi générale
alors certes la france comme beaucoup
d'autres a interdit la vente de paille
et de coton tige en plastique mais c'est
l'équivalent d'une août dans l'océan si
le problème n'est pas suffisamment prise
au sérieux aujourd'hui il fera
certainement trop tard pour y remédier à
l'avenir notre maison brûle et nous
regardons ailleurs vingt ans après cette
déclaration du président jacques chirac
n'a pas pris une ride